image composite editor for ice for short
has been completely redesigned to be
more intuitive and more powerful ice can
turn a collection of photos into a
seamless panorama in just a few steps
import stitch prop and export you can
also start from a video and create a
panorama that includes a moving subject
by indicating key moments in the video
you can tell ice to include these
moments in the final stitched panorama
panoramas often have ragged edges and
cropping them might cut off something
you want to keep instead you can use the
new automatic image completion feature
in ice to fill in the missing parts of
your panorama there's plenty of room to
crop the automatically completed
panorama the latest version of ice
includes support for some new
projections you can use a stereographic
projection to turn a 360 degree panorama
into a little planet image again the
automatic completion feature can fill in
the missing pixels in the center and
around the outside of the image whether
you start from photos or from the video
you're finished panoramas can be saved
as an ordinary image or shared with
others on the Photosynth website
with its redesigned user interface
automatic image completion and the
ability to make panoramas from video ice
lets you express yourself in lots of new
ways have fun creating panoramas with
image composite editor a free download
from Microsoft